buenas tardes valentina como tú lo
decías es una inversión de 600 billones
de dólares de aquí al año 2027 en países
pobres y países emergentes y se hablaba
dos vaivenes porque esta es una idea de
los eeuu que ya fue planteada en el
pasado g7 en el reino unido y que hoy
parece hacerse más concreta básicamente
se trata de inversiones en
infraestructuras primero sanitarias
porque esto se dio en el marco de la
crisis del cob y 19 pero también
infraestructuras para enfatizar la
igualdad de género infraestructuras para
llevar a la transición energética a los
países pobres y disminuir esa
dependencia y esa inseguridad energética
derivada justamente del conflicto en
ucrania en general inversión también en
las tecnologías digitales expandir por
ejemplo las 5 g y las 6 con socios
confiables dijo la casa blanca en
general es una inversión para
contrarrestar la influencia de china
recordemos esas rutas de la ciudad que
tiene el gigante asiático que han
expandido las infraestructuras alrededor
del mundo con préstamos que hace china
que final no son en condiciones muy
ventajosas para los países que las han
recibido se han endeudado y tampoco les
han significado a ellos muchos
beneficios más bien son beneficios para
el 'gigante asiático' la presidenta de
la comisión europea dijo así es como
nosotros el g7 hacemos negocio son
dineros que van a venir por cierto
públicos pero también privados pero con
condiciones más favorables supuestamente
que las de chinas es una agenda
afirmativa dijo mandar leyendo y que
otras iniciativas se espera que salgan
de esta cumbre
si otras iniciativas básicamente que los
países ricos aumente la ayuda al
desarrollo en los últimos años esta se
ha reducido ha sido camuflada como ayuda
a los migrantes en los países donde
llegan por lo tanto que se aumente la
ayuda a los países en desarrollo en
general y bueno que los países ricos se
entreguen ya una agenda en lo que es la
transición energética sobre todo de cara
no acertó al acuerdo de parís
concretamente se han comprometido
recordemos a no financiar más proyectos
de carbón de aquí al 2025 como lo van a
hacer y que terminen de entregar esos 10
mil millones de euros para ayudar a los
países pobres en la transición
energética